to me
when you give money to lobbyists
somebody has to say don't worry about it
I got your back don't worry about it we
got your back keep going nothing's going
to happen to you
play that Reckless where you believe I'm
nothing's really going to happen to you
we got you whether that's lobbyists
whether that's politicians whether
that's whoever you you have to realize
the ripple effect not to say Ripple
excerpty but the ripple effect of an FTX
going down how many YouTube channels
were doing sponsorships about crypto we
got calls from every single crypto
company to for us to do sponsorships we
said no to every single one of them
because it's too it's too you know you
got to be careful taking that kind of
money because you don't know the
stability is not there yet but how many
YouTubers were making oh making 20 grand
a month sponsorship from FTX we go to
meetings one time you and I were with
somebody it's like oh yeah you would be
amazed crypto companies are throwing
money at us